I don't want to be just good I want to
be great I've always been like that
football ended up being the game for me
and I got a chance to go play San Diego
State which was which was amazing I had
some injury issues and some
off-the-field issues that made it tough
and I left the team and I left school I
had to re-evaluate what I'm really into
what I really want to do because the
thing that I poured so much into and
what became my life is gone it's done
it's over it's always good to get hit in
the face sometimes and be humbled it
really brings things back to square one
new tire come on push it there you go
get up it was always about that
fashionable approach even on the playing
field I remember playing high school
football and our coach wouldn't let us
Pat our cleats where you put tape over
them and they look really really cool so
I expanded and just and just took the
punishment the first one is uh this one
on my wrist my dad is like hey out of
respect like wait until you're 18 and
you know out of respect I did wait my
father was the biggest role model I've
ever had he was a pro skateboarder so
that was like one of the first things I
was doing that's when I started taking
notice of details of fashion
I started to had to have certain things
look a certain way
Levi's Dickey's vans
air walks whatever you could afford at
the time but that was like the true
essence of street wear
that's where I started designing but I
always aspired to take it to the next
level as a competitive thing so I took
the time to take classes to learn each
step of making a garment because you
know high fashion you can't fake it
things that I wanted to do were things
that maybe I've been done a couple times
but not like this
the leather teeth a leather tank the
leather sweats which is a piece that
most people were just like what is that
I didn't have a ton of money so I had to
like figure out what would I want to
sample with the money that I had I would
Instagram here and there a couple people
saw it and that started a little wave
for the brand and we were very fortunate
enough to have Kanye take all the
samples he ended up wearing a few that
started that help like noticing ASAP
Rocky JZ is wanted Beyonce one shirt in
that cycle and you're in that wheel the
wheels not stopping for you
hesitation could kill the brand from
that moment on we hit the ground and a
dead sprint I mean we showed Paris
Fashion Week show New York Fashion Week
Barneys
that's like playing at the highest of
levels I mean it's been pretty nice
the French term is in black it's subtle
and monochromatic but it's aggressive
it's in your face the way we're able to
move and shake a big corporate fashion
house can't it's kind of like an unknown
journey but every journey takes a first
step yeah okay I like that one
what's good about our small team is that
we all have the same hunger but also
kind of have that you know street
mentality where you're kind of doing it
a little different ma-1 jacket this is
definitely one of my favorite pieces I
like the juxtaposition of fabrics and
things that you don't make sense the
bulletproof type best silk chiffon with
down fill water snake exotic a rabbit
fur has our custom made on nor zippers
on the backside the tattoo that I have
fortune favors the brave I really want
the branding to come through in the
details this one actually has chain mail
in it and all this had to be hand done
one of the things that we'll continue to
show people that were progressing we
deserve to be here is execution like
this I really like this is a good one so
many people didn't think I was really
doing anything with my life but my dad
is always the one who was like you know
I see where you're going I see what
you're trying to do
make sure we're trying to do the show at
Central Park Jack be very nice yeah like
for him to be able to see what I was
seeing
um was really special and without like
his sacrifice and his forecasting I
there's no way I would have had these
opportunities you went through some
rough times trying to figure out what it
is that he wanted to do I think that
that goes a long ways to keep his feet
on the ground
we've had some success with the brand
but it's always good to be an unfinished
product they're always the underdog
that's just in the natural DNA of Anwar
he got big